et bien sûr QCM la semaine dernière
l'acteur a fait euh Dany Boon une
révélation sur son service militaire
laquelle
il a failli faire carrière dans l'armée
il a été diagnostiqué débile il a fait
de la prison il a déserté son service
militaire bravo
il y a des dettes
on a plein réformé P4 P4 je finissais
pas mes phrases j'étais inconscient j'ai
fait le bout le boubou comme on dit dans
le Nord il comprenait rien à ce que je
disais j'avais l'air totalement débile
non il a été réformé P5 la catégorie des
débiles profonds alors qu'il voulait il
voulait P4 débile léger
et à P6 les jeunes se retrouvaient dans
le service psychiatrique donc faut faire
gaffe quand même tu vois c'est quand
même compliqué il y en a qui ont été
réformes ici moi
on m'a proposé de me réformer j'ai
refusé pourquoi j'ai décidé parce que
c'est des étudiants médecine qui
faisaient le à l'entrée du service
militaire pendant les classes qui
proposait et moi ils m'ont proposé ils
m'ont fait un clin d'oeil d'écrire P4
sur mon truc mais moi je voulais faire
l'armée à ce moment-là une période de
chasse donc je voulais m'engager donc je
dis mais ça serait la pire des infamides
P4 donc j'ai dit non je veux absolument
faire une pilote de chasse mais je
voulais commencer mais mes yeux montre
comment ça pas du tout
mais mes yeux ont trahi
que tous les gens qui veulent pilote de
ligne ou c'est 15 ans d'études à chaque
fois non c'est mes yeux combien de temps
parce que les études pas du tout hein
c'est les yeux Gilbert Montagné et
papillote de ligne
les yeux
alors vas-y Gilbert
[Musique]
ici réformé
[Applaudissements]
HPI déjà SH super homosexuel